disable JavaScript sure now no website
will work at all seriously well let's
conduct an experiment and spend a day
online without JavaScript in fact
statistics show that's one in 500 people
deliberately disable JavaScript a lot
depends on what you're using the
internet for if you just want to watch a
video on YouTube or scroll social media
you won't be able to without JavaScript
but most websites actually work Google
search works most news websites work
even eBay Works no more annoying ads
disabling JavaScript works perfectly for
journalists or those who work with
confidential information however there's
still nothing you can do about those
cookie files so in short if you turn off
JavaScript the internet still works